check out this week's must-see movies if  I show you the rest you have to promise  not to run away miss Peregrine's  delighted to meet miss Peregrine's Home  for peculiar children takes us to an  extraordinary world where anything is  possible  we have been company the thriller  Deepwater Horizon explores the final  hours leading up to the worst oil spill  in US history  well I was destined for a life of  adventure relax  check out masterminds a hilarious comedy  about a night guard who plans the  biggest bank heist in US history you  load up a truck you drive away let's  check out this week's Fanta sebacean so  what's your weekend ticket going to be  let us know by commenting see you next  time on weekend ticket  [Music]